Lucia: 就是做可行性研究报告其中包括
Lucia: They do feasibility studies, including...
Alice:我们的预算
Alice: Our budget...
Alice:是不是告急了
Alice: Is it running out?
Jake: 每人500吧
Jake: 500 per person.
Alice:什么500
Alice: What 500?
Jake: 每人500的那个房间对吧
Jake: 500 per person for the room, right?
Alice:嗯不是我说我说我们总体的
Alice: Hmm, no, I mean our overall budget.
Jake: 总体我们我们还花什么钱吗
Jake: Overall, do we have any other expenses?
Alice:就是
Alice: Exactly.
Katrina:  我们其实主要就吃吃喝喝花了点钱
Katrina: We mostly just spent money on food and drinks.
Lucia: 我们恩格尔系数超高
Lucia: Our Engel coefficient is super high.
Katrina:  哈哈哈确实
Katrina: Haha, that's true.
Jake: 全是身份这个没办法
Jake: It's all about status, there's no other way.
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yeah, this one.
Tasha: 我看附近租的好多都是哈利波特的啊
Tasha: I see a lot of Harry Potter themed rentals nearby.
Alice:因为这有那啥
Alice: Because there's that thing here.
Katrina:  就我们附近的一个公园
Katrina: Just a park near us.
Katrina:  哎就是去看大爷遛弯
Katrina: We just go there to watch old folks take a stroll.
Jake: 就这些都是奢侈品项目里边的奢侈品
Jake: All of these are luxury items within luxury projects.
Jake: 这些都是
Jake: All of these.
Katrina:  昨天30度今天20度
Katrina: It was 30 degrees yesterday, and 20 degrees today.
Tasha: 这好像就那一家可以
Tasha: It seems like only that one place is okay.
Lucia: 如果实在不行也可以
Lucia: If it's really not possible, we can still manage.
Lucia: 就是那种那种那个休闲一点的服装
Lucia: 嗯然后就是可以说便宜点的那种
Lucia: Yeah, and something a bit cheaper.
Lucia: 小小上衣和
Lucia: Like small tops and
Lucia: 牛仔裤或者假的
Lucia: jeans or fake ones.
Lucia: 当然现在关键是大家好像没有
Lucia: But right now, the problem is nobody seems to have
Lucia: 就是就是我们自己的衣服凑
Lucia: just our own clothes to mix and match.
Lucia: 凑不出来
Lucia: Can't put it together.
Lucia: 风格统一的一套否则的话也就
Lucia: A unified style set, otherwise, using our own clothes would work.
Lucia: 是用自己的衣服也行
Lucia: Like when we were in class,
Lucia: 像我们之前上课的时候
Lucia: during our final performance,
Lucia: 就最后汇报表演
Lucia: our teacher picked those
Lucia: 就是我们老师就是挑的那种
Lucia: around 30-40 yuan tops,
Lucia: 就是大概三四十块钱的那种小上衣
Lucia: and pants that were 50-60 yuan.
Lucia: 然后底下一个五六十的那种裤子
Lucia: They might not have had a coherent style,
Lucia: 只不过他可能没有打过风格
Lucia: just a more casual style.
Lucia: 就那种偏稍微休闲一点的风格
Lucia: A slightly more relaxed style.
Tasha: 永乐店
Tasha: Yongle store.
Lucia: 永乐只要统一我觉得就可以
Lucia: As long as it's unified, I think it's fine.
Tasha: 不知道呀搜一搜
Tasha: Not sure, let's search for it.
Jake: 高德在国内是很常用吗
Jake: Is Gaode widely used domestically?
Jake: 嗯就是比百度地图要好
Jake: Yeah, it's better than Baidu Maps.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Katrina:  我觉得比百度好用在界面流畅上
Katrina: I find it better than Baidu in terms of interface smoothness.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Tasha: 好远呢
Tasha: It's pretty far.
Jake: 在哪好远多远
Jake: Where is it? So far away, how far?
Jake: 18公里算了
Jake: 18 kilometers, forget it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  真郊区
Katrina: Really in the suburbs.
Jake: 通州还要再开
Jake: It's still another drive to Tongzhou.
Jake: 18公里
Jake: 18 kilometers.
Katrina:  对通州还要开18公里走
Katrina: Yes, it's another 18 kilometers to Tongzhou.
Shure: 走外卖到了
Shure: Come on, the food delivery is here.
Jake: 走吃饺子吧
Jake: Let's go, eat dumplings.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Shure: 去楼上吃啊
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 走吧
Alice:需要拼不
Alice: Do we need to share?
Alice:对需要内个内
Alice: Yes, we need that, that...
Jake: 那哎
Jake: Ah hey.
Jake: 要醋要带
Jake: We need vinegar, bring it.
Alice:不是不是哦
Alice: No, no, oh.
Jake: 带上去带上去
Jake: Bring it up, bring it up.
Alice:那什么时候录
Alice: When are we recording?
Alice:哎不对
Alice: Ah, wait.
Alice:导数据呢
Alice: What about the data import?
Alice:吃完
Alice: After we eat.
Alice:OK
Alice: OK.
Jake: 吃饺子
Jake: Eat dumplings.
Lucia: ：当然是点了外卖啊我们还
Lucia: Of course, we ordered delivery.
Jake: 哈哈哈好主意
Jake: Haha, good idea.
Jake: 我们包个饺子吧
Jake: Let's make some dumplings.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Jake: 不不不这个太麻烦了
Jake: No, no, that's too troublesome.
Jake: 我们没有什么精力包饺子
Jake: We don't have the energy to make dumplings.
Lucia: 要我们再完成最后一天的任务
Lucia: We still need to complete the last day's tasks.
Alice:上楼
Jake: 对时间还挺紧的
Jake: Yes, time is quite tight.
Katrina:  还要装饰房间
Katrina: Still need to decorate the room.
Katrina:  还要排舞啊
Katrina: And choreograph the dance.
Katrina:  其实还蛮多
Katrina: There's actually a lot.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice:走
Alice:有人一起上楼吗
Alice: Is anyone coming upstairs with me?
Katrina:  有有有
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 嚯这这一身哈利波特吗
Jake: Whoa, is that a whole Harry Potter outfit?
Alice:哈利波特
Alice:嗯来了一个
Alice: Yep, here comes one.
Jake: 我刚刚远远一看
Jake: I just saw it from afar.
Jake: 我觉得这服装到底啥意思啊
Jake: I was wondering what this outfit means.
Jake: 这个啊
Jake: This, huh?
Katrina:  我以为你说来了谁
Katrina: I thought you were talking about who arrived.
Jake: 刚刚他是
Jake: Just when he came over...
Jake: 就是过来的时候他的那个粉色是
Jake: The pink part was about halfway down, it was black.
Jake: 大概到一半就是黑的
Jake: The pink part... your outfit looks great.
Jake: 粉的就是就你这个服装很好看
Jake: Let's go eat.
Jake: 走吃饭去
Jake: Let's go have dumplings.
Jake: 吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go upstairs.
Katrina:  走吧上楼去
Katrina: Yeah, let's go upstairs.
Katrina:  拿瓶醋吧
Katrina: Grab a bottle of vinegar.
Alice:你最爱的醋
Alice: Your favorite vinegar.
Alice:上楼吧
Alice: Let's go upstairs.
Jake: 你们上楼收拾收拾
Jake: You guys go upstairs and tidy up.
Jake: 然后把这边
Jake: Then clear this area...
Jake: 空下来我就
Jake: So that I can...
Jake: 哦是什么
Jake: Oh, what was it?
Jake: 我我我就测一个内餐
Jake: I'll test the inside meal.
Jake: 我测个外餐
Jake: I'll test the outside meal.
Katrina:  没人打扫
Katrina: No one's cleaning.
Katrina:  想打扫就打扫
Katrina: If you want to clean, just clean.
Alice:上楼
Alice: Go upstairs.
Katrina:  我今天早上起来洗个澡
Katrina: I took a shower this morning.
Alice:薇薇薇薇
Alice:等我们结束了之后我去找你玩吧
Alice: After we're done, I'll come find you to hang out.
Alice:收拾一下喽
Alice: Let's tidy up a bit.
Katrina:  有上楼吃饭
Katrina: Let's go upstairs to eat.
Katrina:  楼下的桌子满了呀
Katrina: The tables downstairs are all full.
Katrina:  如何在家自制
Katrina: How to make it at home...
Katrina:  对啊楼上楼下户型都一样
Katrina: Yeah, the layout is the same upstairs and downstairs.
Katrina:  一个客厅再见
Katrina: One living room, see you.
Katrina:  我的拖鞋
Katrina: My slippers.
Katrina:  每个人都有一双这个拖鞋
Katrina: Everyone has a pair of these slippers.
Katrina:  什么呀谢谢
Katrina: What? Thank you.
Katrina:  上次上次帮他给女朋友挑礼物来着
Katrina: Last time, I helped him pick a gift for his girlfriend.
Alice:差不多
Alice:不用碗了吧
Alice: We don't need bowls, right?
Alice:有点烫
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Alice:还给了糖蒜
Alice: They even gave us some sweet garlic.
Alice:哎这不是糖蒜
Alice: Oh, this isn't sweet garlic.
Alice:是腊八蒜
Alice: It's Laba garlic.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊我天呐
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 我一会下我要在下楼把我的线
Lucia: I'll go downstairs in a bit to get my yarn.
Katrina:  这是啥呀
Katrina: What is this?
Alice:腊八蒜
Alice: Laba garlic.
Shure:  吃饺子
Shure: Eat dumplings.
Shure:  这是什么腊八蒜
Shure: What is this Laba garlic?
Katrina:  每天都能给我一点小小的南北方差异
Katrina: Every day, I get a bit of the North-South differences.
Katrina:  震撼
Katrina: It's shocking.
Shure:  你刚才在哼什么
Shure: What were you humming just now?
Katrina:  哎我刚哼的这首歌叫什么来着
Katrina: Oh, what was the name of the song I was humming?
Shure:  你哼的啥
Shure: What were you humming?
Shure:  你再哼一遍
Shure: Hum it again.
Katrina:  忘了
Katrina: Forgot.
Katrina:  7秒钟的记忆
Katrina: I have a 7-second memory.
Katrina:  是告五人的
Katrina: It's by Accusefive.
Shure:  没有这个印象
Shure: I don't remember that.
（歌词）完美的胜利
(Lyrics) Perfect victory.
（歌词）一辈在这里
(Lyrics) A lifetime here.
（歌词）有些事真回忆
(Lyrics) Some things are real memories.
（歌词）我们的爱情
(Lyrics) Our love.
Katrina:  就这首歌
Katrina: It's this song.
Shure:  霉霉发新专了
Shure: Taylor released a new album.
Shure:  已经不是霉粉了
Shure: I'm not a Swiftie anymore.
Shure:  那你说你上一张专辑你你最爱听
Shure: So, what's your favorite song from her last album?
Shure:  哈哈哈什么东西
Shure: Hahaha, what is it?
Shure:  你看这种又当又立这种
Shure: Look at this person being all contradictory.
其他人：然后呢从现在开始回馈嘛
Others: And then, from now on, let's give back.
Katrina:  倒点醋
Katrina: Pour some vinegar.
Shure:  你演唱会你不是把票卖了吗
Shure: Didn't you sell your concert ticket?
Katrina:  这是啥
Katrina: What is this?
Shure:  啊嗨
Shure: Ah, hey.
Shure:  你摸到霉霉大腿了吗
Shure: Did you touch Taylor's thigh?
其他人：梅梅离我就10米
Others: Taylor was just 10 meters away from me.
其他人：要是在中楼我肯定冲上去摸
Others: If I was in the middle row, I would have definitely rushed up to touch her.
其他人：新加坡不太敢
Others: Singapore doesn't dare much.
Shure:  法律比较严格是吧
Shure: The laws are pretty strict, right?
其他人：怕被鞭
Others: Afraid of getting caned.
Katrina:  这是韭菜饼是吧
Katrina: Is this a chive pancake?
Jake: 是吧摸什么
Jake: Yeah, why are you touching it?
其他人：就是我离每位最低就10米
Others: I'm at least 10 meters away from everyone.
其他人：因为我冲到第一排
Others: Because I rushed to the front row.
Katrina:  那票多少钱
Katrina: How much was the ticket?
Katrina:  前排
Katrina: For the front row.
Shure:  差一点成功虽然味可能不太一样
Shure: Almost made it, though the taste might be different.
其他人：就不要再问了
Others: Just don't ask anymore.
其他人：有点悲惨的故事
Others: It's kind of a sad story.
Jake: 那就更要问了
Jake: Then we have to ask!
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 也蛮神奇的
Lucia: It's pretty amazing.
其他人：有点悲惨故事
Others: Kind of a sad story.
Katrina:  你可以去参加那个6句话的故事
Katrina: You could join that 6-word story thing.
Katrina:  6句话感觉你都说不完了
Katrina: I feel like you can't finish it in 6 words.
Shure:  反正吃完12点了
Shure: Anyway, it's past midnight.
Katrina:  嘉和一品
Katrina: Jiahe Yipin.
Shure:  还行不是还有其他的
Shure: It's okay, there are other places too.
Katrina:  成了
Katrina: Got it.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  探险的这费劲
Shure: Exploring this is tough.
Shure:  这整的大块探一点不好找
Shure: It's hard to find big pieces like this.
Shure:  然后还买少了呢趟
Shure: And I bought too few.
Shure:  on go on
Shure: On go on.
Shure:  谁到了
Shure: Who's here?
Katrina: 这个谁要碗
Katrina: Who wants a bowl?
Alice:拿不拿都行
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Katrina:  我自己有了
Katrina: I have one already.
Katrina:  想喝又想喝饮料
Katrina: Want to drink, but also want a drink.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 抹布比碗还油
Lucia: The cloth is oilier than the bowl.
Shure:  你长得跟跟跟哎呀
Shure: You look like, like, oh man.
Lucia: 应该使用突破型的词
Lucia: Should use more impactful words.
Shure:  行完完完再说
Shure: Alright, alright, let's talk later.
Shure:  不着急不着急
Shure: No rush, no rush.
Alice:你那个是什么材质
Alice: What's that made of?
Alice:呃下边那个
Alice: Uh, the one below
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:这是一串的
Alice: This is a whole string of them
Katrina:  今天是第几天第四天吧
Katrina: What day is it today? The fourth day, right?
Katrina:  笑的跟那个老鼠一样哈哈
Katrina: Laughing like a mouse, haha
Alice:哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thank you
Alice:像虎鲸又不太像虎鲸
Alice: Looks like an orca, but not quite like an orca
Alice:查一下
Jake: 开吃
Jake: Let's eat
Jake: 缺人是吧
Jake: Missing someone, right?
Shure:  这家伙给整了
Shure: This guy is done
Jake: 一堆人紧张这家伙
Jake: A bunch of people are nervous about this guy
Lucia: 呃那你走了碗就不动了
Lucia: Uh, if you leave, the bowl won't move
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, haha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 碗是死的
Lucia: The bowl is dead
Lucia: 你是活的
Lucia: You're alive
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 我们也可以让碗活起来
Jake: We can make the bowl come alive too
Jake: 全是青草全是草
Jake: It's all grass, all grass
Jake: 一桌子草
Jake: A table full of grass
其他人：草对
Others: Grass, yes
其他人：显得苏显
Others: Looks fresh
Jake: 哈哈知道为什么吗
Jake: Haha, do you know why?
Jake: 就今天是一个节气
Jake: Because today is a solar term
其他人：谷雨嗯
Others: Grain Rain, hmm
Jake: 嗯你怎么知道的
Jake: Hmm, how did you know?
其他人：我刷到了公众号
Others: I saw it on a public account
其他人：但是我不知道谷雨是干嘛的
Others: But I don't know what Grain Rain is for
Jake: 谷雨是干嘛的
Jake: What is Grain Rain for?
Jake: 谷雨是种种地
Jake: Grain Rain is for planting crops
Jake: 嗯要下雨了
Jake: Hmm, it's going to rain
Katrina:  不知道你这些买的都是什么馅
Katrina: I don't know what fillings you bought
Katrina:  都是
Katrina: All of them
Alice:那是清明前后种瓜点豆
Alice: That's for planting melons and beans around the Qingming Festival
Jake: 哦种东西
Jake: Oh, planting things
其他人：所以谷雨就要吃菜
Others: So for Grain Rain, we should eat vegetables
Alice:春菜
Alice: Spring vegetables
Jake: 长完了可以吃了应该
Jake: They've grown, so we can eat them now, I guess
Alice:嗯主要是香椿
Alice: Hmm, mainly Chinese toon
Alice:香椿在谷雨之后就木质了
Alice: The Chinese toon becomes woody after the Grain Rain.
Jake: 这什么馅的
Jake: What's the filling?
Jake: 他有两种馅
Jake: There are two kinds of fillings.
其他人：正好是韭菜韭菜鸡蛋
Others: It's just right, chive and egg.
Jake: 韭菜鸡蛋和肉
Jake: Chive and egg, and meat.
Katrina:  有肉的
Katrina: There's meat.
Jake:那就是什么
Jake: So what is it?
Jake: 什么芹菜
Jake: What kind of celery?
Katrina:  把醋倒这了
Katrina: Pour the vinegar here.
Jake: 要醋有芹菜吗这里面
Jake: Does it need vinegar, is there celery in it?
Jake: 还是白菜啊
Jake: Or is it cabbage?
Katrina:  那衣服是
Katrina: That outfit is...
Katrina:  是租还是什么
Katrina: Is it rented or what?
Katrina:  你给个预算然后我们办事
Katrina: Give us a budget and we'll handle it.
Lucia: 要我给你出可行性研究报告吗
Lucia: Do you want me to prepare a feasibility study report?
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha.
Jake: 我我我估一下
Jake: I'll estimate it.
Jake: 我算一算现在是什么
Jake: Let me calculate, what is it now?
Jake: 如果是买的话最便宜是多少
Jake: If we buy it, what's the cheapest price?
Tasha: 40是买的上衣
Tasha: 40 is for the top.
Alice:40
Alice: 40.
Tasha: 算了吧我现在看到了有一个
Tasha: Never mind, I just saw one.
Tasha: 全部都是25元的一套
Tasha: Everything is 25 yuan for a set.
Jake: 什么东西啊25块钱
Jake: What is 25 yuan?
Tasha: 你要来看吗
Tasha: Do you want to see it?
Jake: 没事
Jake: No need.
Lucia: 你要还喝可乐吗
Lucia: Do you still want to drink Coke?
Jake: 喝我来喝
Jake: Yes, I'll drink it.
Jake: 我先把这是我的咖啡
Jake: Let me finish my coffee first.
Lucia: 这你的吗
Lucia: Is this yours?
Jake: 我先把咖啡喝了
Jake: Let me finish the coffee first.
Lucia: OK那我不管你了好
Lucia: Okay, then I won't bother you anymore.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 自己看着办吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Just handle it yourself, hahaha.
Tasha: 您就是老板
Tasha: You're the boss.
Tasha: 动都不动
Tasha: You don't move at all.
Jake: 是老板就说你看着办吧
Jake: Being the boss means you just say "handle it yourself".
Jake: 呵呵这是谢谢您
Jake: Haha, thank you.
Jake:这啥呀哇
Jake: What is this, wow.
Jake: 这是哪翻来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Tasha: 但是这个是长沙的
Tasha: But this one is in Changsha.
Tasha: 所以他要租三天
Tasha: So he needs to rent it for three days.
Tasha: 那三天
Tasha: Those three days.
Tasha: 就是呃
Tasha: It's like, um...
Lucia: 就衣服到粉的情况下是三天
Lucia: So if the clothes arrive in pink, it's three days.
Lucia: 第一天到第二天用第三天退
Lucia: Use it from the first day to the second day and return it on the third day.
Tasha: 嗯对所以他其实是25块钱好像
Tasha: Hmm, right. So it's actually 25 bucks, I think.
Tasha: 嗯我看看他是这么写的吧
Tasha: Hmm, let me see if that's what it says.
Tasha: 你看18啊
Tasha: Look, 18, huh?
Tasha: 三天
Tasha: Three days.
Jake: 好好好这个预算可以
Jake: Okay, okay, this budget is doable.
Jake: 这个远远没到预算
Jake: This is way under budget.
Jake: 哈哈其实我也不知道预算多少
Jake: Haha, actually, I don't even know what the budget is.
Jake: 但是那1,000的话肯定过分了
Jake: But if it's 1,000, that's definitely too much.
Jake: 500以上肯定多
Jake: Anything over 500 is definitely too much.
Katrina:  确实只穿一次
Katrina: Yeah, it's just for one-time use.
Tasha: 但是这个的话就是在长沙
Tasha: But this one is in Changsha.
Tasha: 他要租的话可能就要三天起
Tasha: If he wants to rent it, it might be at least three days.
Tasha: 就只有这一套
Tasha: There's only this set.
Tasha: 他是把
Tasha: He...
Tasha: 还有这种
Tasha: And this kind...
Tasha: 他好像都是40吧
Tasha: I think they're all 40, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 这一套
Tasha: This set.
Tasha: 是吧一套两套
Tasha: Right? One set, two sets.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 但是如果是这家店的话他就在通州嘛
Tasha: But if it's this shop, it's in Tongzhou.
Tasha: 嗯但他们家好像比较贵
Tasha: Hmm, but their stuff seems pretty expensive.
Tasha: 他说点购买就可以知道了
Tasha: He said you can know by checking the purchase.
Tasha: 第一套是25块钱
Tasha: The first set is 25 bucks.
Tasha: 第二套就要2550358045403520
Tasha: The second set is 25 50 35 80 45 40 35 20.
Alice:哎呀，好大
Lucia: 你们现在用的是
Lucia: Are you using that yellow app now?
Lucia: 那个黄色的那个小软件吗
Lucia: The cheap one?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia: 嗯便宜
Lucia: Yeah, cheap.
Katrina:  闲鱼是个好东西
Katrina: Idle Fish is a good thing.
Jake: 一人50左右吧行吧
Jake: Around 50 per person, right?
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Jake: 可可行吗
Jake: Is that alright?
Lucia: 可行应该是可行
Lucia: Should be okay.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina:  但是哈利波特衣服一天都只要50块
Katrina: But the Harry Potter outfit is only 50 yuan per day.
Lucia: 但是我最好是能
Lucia: But I'd rather...
Lucia: 我们能在附近找到一个实体店租哦
Lucia: We find a physical store nearby to rent from.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 因为寄过来的话有一个稍微有点慢
Lucia: Because if they mail it, it might be a bit slow.
Tasha: 但是那个的话还挺
Tasha: But that's still...
Jake: 没亮
Jake: It didn't light up.
Tasha: 对挺远的
Tasha: Yeah, it's quite far.
Tasha: 然后25块钱一套
Tasha: And it's 25 yuan per set.
Tasha: 那一家他居然连鞋子都配
Tasha: That place even includes shoes.
Tasha: 配饰也都配
Tasha: And accessories too.
Katrina:  这么专业啊
Katrina: So professional.
Shure:  每次谢运中一来就
Shure: Every time Xie Yunzhong comes...
Shure:  咱们就开始练团是吧
Shure: We start band practice, right?
Jake: 对哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, haha.
Shure: 卧槽我这时间来的太不巧了哈
Shure: Damn, my timing is so off.
Jake: 哈哈哈我有筷子
Jake: Haha, I have chopsticks.
Katrina:  没有餐具了吗
Katrina: No utensils left?
Jake: 给俩勺子可以
Jake: Two spoons should be fine.
Alice:这有啥没用的
Alice: What's the use of that?
Shure:  别别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  咱又不是没筷子
Shure: We do have chopsticks.
Alice:那个柜子里好多筷子
Alice: There's a lot of chopsticks in that cabinet.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  给我倒一点
Shure: Pour me some.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Alice:这是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Is this celery leaf?
Shure:  我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  香椿
Shure: It's toon.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one?
Alice:这个不是香椿味吧
Alice: This doesn't taste like toon.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice:不像香椿
Alice: Doesn't seem like toon.
Tasha: 我们都有这么多鸡蛋了
Tasha: We have so many eggs.
Tasha: 还要买个打鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Do we still need to buy an egg beater?
Lucia: 就是只要我在家就敢吃炒蛋哈哈
Lucia: As long as I'm home, I dare to eat scrambled eggs, haha.
Lucia: 笑话好冷
Lucia: That joke was so lame.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不是真不是我要逼迫大家吃的
Lucia: No, really, I'm not forcing everyone to eat it.
其他人：这个炒鸡蛋好吃啊
Others: This scrambled egg is delicious.
Lucia: 那就行不是
Lucia: That's good, isn't it?
Lucia: 不是这些不是我点的
Lucia: But I didn't order these.
Lucia: 不要误会
Lucia: Don't misunderstand.
Lucia: 哎这啥情况
Lucia: Hey, what's going on?
Lucia: 又掉线了
Lucia: Disconnected again.
Jake: 又掉线了
Jake: Disconnected again.
Jake: 对好吧
Jake: Yeah, okay.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 那就再连上吧
Jake: Then reconnect it.
Lucia: 但他应该有电
Lucia: But it should have power.
Lucia: 那为啥
Lucia: Then why...
Alice:杨老板这个是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Jake, are these celery leaves?
Jake: 呃我看一下菜单
Jake: Uh, let me check the menu.
Lucia: 新鲜
Lucia: Fresh.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 今天是19
Lucia: Today is the 19th.
Jake: 呃这应该就是香椿苗炒鸡蛋
Jake: Uh, this should be Chinese toon sprouts scrambled eggs.
Alice:这个是香椿苗
Alice: This is Chinese toon sprouts?
Jake: 那就是叫它叫老味道蒸菜
Jake: They call it "Old Flavor Steamed Vegetables."
Jake: 我不知道是什么
Jake: I don't know what it is.
Jake: 我看一下啊
Jake: Let me take a look.
Alice:好质感好质感
Alice: The texture is so good.
Lucia: 我想夹一个那个蛋
Lucia: I want to grab one of those eggs.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Lucia: 这他是锅贴吗
Lucia: Is this a potsticker?
Shure:  差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
其他人：我没吃过
Others: I've never tried it.
其他人：我一直以为这种东西叫锅贴
Others: I always thought this kind of thing was called a potsticker.
Alice:哦下面还有层嗯
Alice: Oh, there's another layer below, hmm.
其他人：卧槽上面还有一层
Others: Whoa, there's another layer on top.
Lucia: 哦这种东西叫锅贴
Lucia: Oh, this kind of thing is called a potsticker.
Lucia: 那这个是什么
Lucia: Then what is this?
Lucia: 尝一下
Lucia: I'll give it a try.
Alice:为什么没有人吃腊八蒜
Alice: Why is no one eating the Laba garlic?
Shure:  我吃糖蒜
Shure: I eat sweet garlic.
Shure:  但不吃腊八蒜
Shure: But not Laba garlic.
Alice:为啥
Alice: Why?
Katrina:  少忽悠我
Katrina: Stop fooling me.
Shure:  不是腊八蒜
Shure: It's not Laba garlic.
Alice:腊八蒜
Alice: Laba garlic
Alice:糖蒜有皮
Alice: Sweet garlic with skin
Jake: 那是什么蒜
Jake: What kind of garlic is that?
Alice:腊八蒜腊八蒜
Alice: Laba garlic, Laba garlic
Shure:  腊八蒜他这个是就是熟的蒜
Shure: Laba garlic is basically cooked garlic
Shure:  那个糖弄糖蒜的时候是那种新鲜的蒜
Shure: When making sweet garlic, you use fresh garlic
Shure:  就是那种
Shure: Like the kind
Shure:  没没没烘过的那种蒜
Shure: That hasn't been dried
Lucia: 看起来像一个饼
Lucia: It looks like a pancake
Jake: 早餐10块
Jake: Breakfast for 10 yuan
Jake: 饼
Jake: Pancake
Jake: 撕了吧
Jake: Tear it apart
Jake: 就在这撕了吧
Jake: Just tear it apart here
Jake: 就在这撕掉
Jake: Just tear it apart
Jake: 看看怎么撕
Jake: Let's see how to tear it
Shure:  撕什么
Shure: Tear what?
Jake:撕饼
其他人：来吃一个要13年
Others: Come eat one, it takes 13 years
其他人：27开始吃
Others: Start eating at 27
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Lucia: 这也是香椿的吗
Lucia: Is this also Chinese toon?
Alice:这个是茴香的
Alice: This one is fennel
Jake: 撕完了哎
Jake: Finished tearing
Alice:4万哎还有4万
Alice: 40,000, there's still 40,000
Jake: 没撕完还有一个
Jake: Not finished, there's one more
Alice:还有一个
Alice: There's one more
Jake: 自行认领
Jake: Take it yourself
Katrina:  我觉得吃两个就吃饱了
Katrina: I think eating two is enough
Jake: 你说8个
Jake: You said eight
Katrina:  我今天早上吃多了面包
Katrina: I had too much bread this morning
Katrina:  今天早上那个
Katrina: This morning
Alice:要那个馅的吗
Alice: Want that filling?
Katrina:  自己做面包
Katrina: Made bread myself
Alice:给你加几个
Alice: I'll add some for you
Katrina:  烤面包大厨的感觉
Katrina: Feeling like a master baker
Tasha: 不知道什么东西
Tasha: No idea what that is
Katrina:  黄油面包
Katrina: Butter bread
Shure:  昨天没吃到
Shure: Didn't get any yesterday
Shure:  我的我的
Shure: Mine, mine
Shure:  我的肉
Shure: My meat
Shure:  虽然不是我烤的吧
Shure: Even though I didn’t grill it
Shure:  你应该感到很悲伤吧
Shure: You must feel really sad
Jake: 我们几点考完来着
Jake: What time did we finish grilling?
Jake: 9点半10点半
Jake: 9:30 or 10:30
Alice:10点半
Alice: 10:30
Jake:10点半跑完
Jake: Finished grilling by 10:30
Alice:嗯 12点快12点吧
Alice: Yeah, almost 12
Jake: 肯定烤上
Jake: Definitely grilled
Jake: 什么时候烤上呢
Jake: When did we start grilling?
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea
Katrina:  搞碳搞了半天
Katrina: Took forever with the charcoal
Katrina:  我看看拍照时间
Katrina: Let me check the photo time
Alice:每根头发丝都裹裹满了那个烟的味道
Alice: Every hair is covered with the smell of smoke
Katrina:  真的是所以必须要洗到洗
Katrina: Yeah, definitely need to wash it
Shure:  昨天晚上我还倒头就睡了
Shure: Last night I just fell asleep immediately
Shure:  我靠昨天晚上
Shure: Last night, I just laid down
Shure:  躺那躺一会
Shure: Laid down for a bit
Shure:  然后就着了
Shure: And then fell asleep
其他人：结果我那那一天中秋还回去
Others: I had to go back for Mid-Autumn Festival
其他人：我准备两点钟躺一会
Others: Planned to lie down at 2
其他人：躺到3点看个班
Others: Lie down till 3 and watch the game
其他人：结果躺到了12点
Others: Ended up lying till 12
Jake: 谁赢了
Jake: Who won?
其他人：嗯打平了
Others: It was a draw
其他人：最后点球皇马赢了
Others: Real Madrid won on penalties
其他人：还好我没看
Others: Good thing I didn’t watch
Jake: 是吧你
Jake: Right?
Jake: 你是曼城球迷
Jake: You're a Man City fan
Jake: 哈兰德
Jake: Haaland
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  曼彻斯特
Shure: Manchester
其他人：我这姆巴佩的球
Others: I’m into Mbappe
其他人：所以我很期
Others: So I’m excited
其他人：所以我很期待姆巴佩打皇马
Others: I’m excited to see Mbappe against Real Madrid
其他人：因为姆巴佩马上要去皇马
Others: Because Mbappe is going to Real Madrid soon
其他人：看看他怎么操作
Others: Let’s see how he performs
Lucia: 他真的要去皇马了吗
Lucia: Is he really going to Real Madrid?
其他人：好像差不多
Others: Seems like it
Jake: 打巴黎赢了吗
Jake: Did they beat PSG?
其他人：没有
Others: No
Jake: 就是要打皇马
Jake: We have to play against Real Madrid
其他人：那马上还要打多特
Others: Then we also have to play against Dortmund
其他人：然后皇马打多特蒙德
Others: And then Real Madrid will play against Dortmund
其他人：哦好吧打败了
Others: Oh, alright, they lost
其他人：大巴黎打多特
Others: PSG will play against Dortmund
Jake: 我以前都不知道
Jake: I didn't know before
Jake: 达瓦尼自从我做这个和这个
Jake: Ever since I started doing this and that
Jake: 啊就这个是我们
Jake: Ah, this is our...
Jake: 我2022年的一篇paper
Jake: My 2022 paper
Jake: 他态度比较
Jake: His attitude was quite...
Jake: 这个叫叫panelbig
Jake: This thing called panelbig
其他人：你这个当时一看就是大巴黎
Others: You could tell it was PSG at first glance
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, that's it
Jake: 是80年代TSG
Jake: It's PSG from the 80s
Jake: 就是大巴黎的那个logo
Jake: It's the PSG logo
Jake: 嗯然后我们稍微改造改造
Jake: Hmm, we made some modifications
Jake: 改成了我们这个分割的
Jake: Changed it to our segmented one
Jake: 就它是一个情景分割
Jake: It's a situational segmentation
Jake: 嗯一看是青年分支
Jake: Hmm, you can see it's a youth branch
Jake: 就就就割出来的这个东西
Jake: Just this segment
Shure:  所以这个跟大巴黎是真的有关系是吗
Shure: So this really is related to PSG?
Jake: 简称是就是PSG啊
Jake: The abbreviation is just PSG
Jake: 就硬凑一个简称
Jake: We just forced an abbreviation
Shure:  就是正好这个简称是一样的是吗
Shure: So the abbreviation just happens to be the same?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 就是先出了这个名字
Jake: The name came first
Jake: 然后简称PSG
Jake: Then the abbreviation PSG
Jake: 然后我上网一搜
Jake: Then I searched online
Jake: 我靠是个球队
Jake: Damn, it's a team
Jake: 哈哈我才知道
Jake: Haha, that's when I found out
Lucia: 反应是的有点慢
Lucia: Your reaction was a bit slow
Shure:  大巴黎他不止有球队
Shure: PSG doesn't just have a team
Shure:  还有那个电竞的队伍嗯
Shure: They also have an esports team, hmm
Shure:  吃困了
Shure: I'm so sleepy after eating
Shure:  吃完就想睡
Shure: I want to sleep right after eating
Shure:  睡醒了就饿
Shure: When I wake up, I'm hungry
Shure:  饿完就想吃
Shure: When I'm hungry, I want to eat
Alice:闭环了
Alice: It's a closed loop
Shure:  感觉人生已经
Shure: Feels like life is already...
Jake: 对这才是生活
Jake: Yeah, this is life.
Jake: 一个life就应该这个样子
Jake: A life should be like this.
Jake: 跟里面夹了很多戏
Jake: There's a lot of drama in it.
Jake: 太那个了
Jake: It's just too much.
其他人：不真实哈哈哈
Others: It's not realistic, hahaha.
其他人：应该是吧
Others: Probably, yeah.
Shure:  明天床上躺一天啊
Shure: Lying in bed all day tomorrow, huh?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  像只蛆一样的蠕动
Shure: Wriggling like a maggot.
其他人：不是在床上躺一天
Others: Not lying in bed all day.
其他人：你应该给我300
Others: You should give me 300 bucks.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  我靠我让你看我在床上躺着
Shure: Damn, I'll show you me lying in bed.
其他人：你兜着开枪呗
Others: You shoot with your phone.
其他人：我又看不到你操
Others: I can't see you anyway, damn.
Shure:  那我把眼镜放这块
Shure: Then I'll put my glasses here.
Shure:  然后让他拍
Shure: And let him film.
Shure:  我躺着就是让他
Shure: I'll be lying down and let him.
Jake: 那为什么会眼镜
Jake: Why would there be glasses?
Shure:  人类是一个草履虫
Shure: Humans are like paramecia.
Shure:  只能进行简单的生命活动
Shure: We can only perform simple life activities.
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命啊
Lucia: Hahaha, help me!
Shure:  感觉吃的差不多了
Shure: I feel like I've eaten enough.
Shure:  我好饿啵啵
Shure: I'm so hungry, bop bop.
Shure:  呸我好好饱
Shure: No, I'm so full.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 新中医什么时候答辩
Jake: When is the new Chinese medicine defense?
Jake: 模拟答辩
Jake: The mock defense.
Katrina:  这跟导师有关
Katrina: It depends on the supervisor.
Katrina:  我以为是学员
Katrina: I thought it was the student.
Jake: 就学院要求
Jake: Just the academy's requirement.
Jake: 但是导师不管
Jake: But the supervisor doesn't care.
其他人：但是按道理
Others: But logically.
其他人：我的导师应该会给我打最高
Others: My supervisor should give me the highest score.
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：因为他前几次从来没看过都是最高分
Others: Because he never looked before and always gave the highest scores.
Lucia: 哇这样的导师哪里找
Lucia: Wow, where can I find such a supervisor?
其他人：然后之前
Others: And before.
其他人：我还问了一下
Others: I even asked once.
其他人：就我的导师是我老板他他带
其他人：然后他被名额了刮了一个导师
Others: Then he got a mentor position.
其他人：然后还问了个老板
Others: And then he asked a boss.
其他人：我说我要不要去加一下他微信啊
Others: I said, should I add him on WeChat?
其他人：要不要搞
Others: Should we do it?
其他人：他说能不反弹尽量别反弹
Others: He said if you can avoid it, try not to.
Jake: 反他就扣分
Jake: If you do, you'll lose points.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  你只要跟我说一句话我就给你扣一分
Shure: If you say one word to me, I'll deduct a point.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：我到现在我到现在没跟他讲过一句话
Others: Up till now, I haven't said a single word to him.
Jake: 准备满分准备满分
Jake: Prepare for full marks, prepare for full marks.
Jake: 准备满分
Jake: Prepare for full marks.
其他人：刚只说过一次
Others: I only spoke once.
其他人：最开始给他发了邮件
Others: Initially, I sent him an email.
其他人：他回我一切信息
Others: He replied to all my messages.
其他人：请不要联系我
Others: Please don't contact me.
其他人：联系男老师就行
Others: Just contact the male teacher.
Shure:  男老师是什么东西
Shure: What's a male teacher?
其它人：就是刚才的那个
其他人：我们最近的地点是20号叫中文名称
Others: Our latest location is on the 20th, named in Chinese.
其他人：    嗯然后就24号叫PPT
Others: And then on the 24th, it's called PPT.
Shure:  嗯 24号叫final report
Shure: Yeah, the 24th is the final report.
Shure:  30号
Shure: The 30th.
其他人：PPT呢 30号PPT
Others: PPT, on the 30th, the PPT.
其他人：30号中间没有了
Others: There's nothing in between on the 30th.
Alice:21号章没了
Alice: The 21st stamp is gone.
Shure:  没有24号
Shure: There's no 24th.
Shure:  就是所有周边材料
Shure: All the surrounding materials.
Shure:  加上那个那什么都要交
Shure: Plus whatever else needs to be handed in.
其他人：之前老记
Others: Always remember before.
其他人：着r e原来那个是Louis的DJ啊
Others: The original one was Louis' DJ.
Shure:  那是他什么的弟弟啊
Shure: That was his brother?
其他人：他们拿他们写draft啊
Others: They wrote the draft for them.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure:  你drop的写多少了
Shure: How much did you write for your drop?
其他人：我高中就写了19页
Others: I wrote 19 pages in high school.
Shure:  好
Shure: Good.
Jake: 我当年毕设什么初期报告忘交了
Jake: Back then, I forgot to submit my initial report for my graduation project.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 对对恶劣伪报扣了10%
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it was so bad, I got 10% deducted.
其他人：错了10% 要搞那个什么时间
Others: Wrong by 10%. We need to fix that timing thing.
Shure:  对最后90
Shure: Yeah, the last 90.
其他人：为什么你想为什么
Others: Why do you think that?
Shure: 是因为你导师很好
Shure:  是因为人家做的很牛逼
Shure: It's because their work is excellent.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Shure:  你这你就是你
Shure: You are, you just are...
Shure:  这孩子不会说话
Shure: This kid doesn't know how to speak.
Shure:  领导都把话递到这了
Shure: The leader has already brought it up.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎呦我的
Shure: Haha, oh my...
Shure:  妈呀这是为什么
Shure: Why is this happening?
Shure:  你们导师好啊
Shure: Your mentor is really good.
Jake: 导师确实
Jake: The mentor really is.
其他人：只有只有好的导师才会招最强的人
Others: Only good mentors attract the best people.
其他人：你知道吗
Others: You know that, right?
其他人：一般好的都一抢而空
Others: The good ones are always snapped up quickly.
其他人： 只有能力强才能抢到这种名额
Others: Only the capable ones can get such positions.
Shure:  别找补了
Shure: Stop making excuses.
Shure:  明年科员都不一定是了
Shure: Next year, you might not even be a staff member.
Shure:  哈哈你快去山东进修两年吧
Shure: Haha, you should go to Shandong for two years of training.
Alice:哈哈哈山东
Alice: Hahaha, Shandong.
Shure:  山东
Shure: Shandong.
其他人：90分感觉有点夸张
Others: 90 points seems a bit exaggerated.
其他人：没见过这么高
Others: Never seen it that high.
Shure:  我一多一分我都不要
Shure: I don't want even one point more.
Shure:  他只要给我60就行
Shure: As long as I get 60, I'm good.
Tasha: 为什么要考90分
Tasha: Why aim for 90 points?
Lucia: 他考了90分
Lucia: He scored 90 points.
Tasha: 他考了90分
Tasha: He scored 90 points.
Lucia: 嗯哦
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 我还以为啊
Tasha: I thought...
Shure:  我说我要60分就行
Shure: I said I just want 60 points.
Shure:  你多一分都是多给我的都没有用
Shure: Any extra points are just unnecessary.
其他人：你企战是60吗
Others: Your strategic management score is 60?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  企站是什么
Shure: What is strategic management?
Jake: 企业战略我都记得啊
Jake: I remember all about strategic management.
Shure:  不是应该不是60
Shure: No, it shouldn't be 60.
其他人：我整整60
Other: I got exactly 60
其他人：为什么说我
Other: Why are you talking about me?
其他人：就是我考试非常想提前交卷嘛
Other: I really wanted to hand in my exam early
其他人：然后呢
Other: And then
其他人：那个考试在考试期我实在是真的不会
Other: During the exam, I really didn't know how to answer
其他人：然后我本来是有时间复习的
Other: I actually had time to study
其他人：但那段时间繁华太好看了
Other: But that show was too good to watch
其他人：我就一直在看繁华
Other: So I kept watching it
其他人：  所以那个真的没出息
Other: So yeah, I was really hopeless
Shure:  我带他看哈哈哈
Shure: I watched it with him, haha
其他人：然后考试的时候我三三十多分的交卷
Other: And during the exam, I handed in with only thirty-something points
其他人：   因为我一堂课没跟你差不多
Other: Because I didn't attend a single class
其他人：因为我一堂课没有去过
Other: I never went to a single class
其他人：所以我不知道老师长什么样
Other: So I didn't know what the teacher looked like
其他人：其实那个监
Other: Actually, the invigilator
其他人：考老师就是我们的老师
Other: Was our teacher
其他人：但是我不知道
Other: But I didn't know
其他人：我以为他只是一个小小学生
Other: I thought he was just a little student
Lucia: 小学生小学生真是
Lucia: A little student, really
Alice:小学生
Alice: A little student
其他人：我就直接交了
Other: So I just handed it in
其他人：交了之后还是他跟我说的
Other: After handing it in, he told me
Shure:  老师在这阴阳怪气的
Shure: The teacher was being sarcastic
Shure:  我拿他卷跟你讲啊
Shure: I took his paper and told him
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure:  就这种这么早交卷的
Shure: The one who handed in so early
Shure:  一字不写的
Shure: With barely anything written
Shure:  不是不是不是没写几个字的
Shure: No, no, not barely, almost nothing
Shure:  这肯肯定过不了
Shure: There's no way he could pass
Shure:  那肯必须挂他
Shure: He definitely needs to fail
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 那最后没挂呀
Lucia: But in the end, he didn't fail
其他人：只能说老师这太好了
Other: I can only say the teacher was really nice
其他人：可能看我写的屁话太多了不
Other: Maybe because I wrote too much nonsense
Shure:  不不是
Shure: No, no
Shure:  然后他他他说完这番话我就添两个字
Shure: And after he said that, I added two more words
Shure:  我就咔就笑了哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Then I just laughed, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：回来把这个把这个噩耗传给我
Others: Came back and delivered this bad news to me.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  我就想想赶紧告诉他这个好消息
Shure: I just wanted to quickly tell him this good news.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
其他人：然后我整个寒假都没过好
Others: And my entire winter break was ruined.
Shure:  我们两个
Shure: The two of us.
其他人：我感觉我们两个傻逼学了一个寒假
Others: I feel like the two of us idiots studied the whole winter break.
Jake: 学了一个
Jake: Studied for a...
Jake: 喊他起人哈哈哈
Jake: Called him to get up, haha.
其他人：还是不会学
Others: Still couldn't learn.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 是学不了一点
Lucia: Couldn't learn a bit.
Alice:哈哈哈不会学
Alice: Hahaha, couldn't learn.
Jake: 哈哈哈单身可以
Jake: Hahaha, being single is okay.
Shure:  他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure:  我还有一门课
Shure: I still have one course.
Shure:  因为平时有一次测测验没去
Shure: Because I missed a quiz once.
Shure:  就是平时小测
Shure: Just a small quiz.
Shure:  然后我因为那天那个实习有有事
Shure: That day I had something to do at my internship.
Shure:  然后我就问那老师
Shure: So I asked the professor.
Shure:  我说平时分
Shure: I said, the regular grade...
Shure:  咱那个没过
Shure: Although I didn't pass, if my final grade passes, can I pass?
Shure:  但是我总成绩过了能不能给我过
Shure: He said yes.
Shure:  他说可以的
Shure: But then he failed me in the end.
Shure:  然后结果最后给我挂了
Shure: And made me retake it.
Shure:  然后让我重新补了一遍
Shure: The small quiz again.
Shure:  平时小册
Shure: It was so humiliating.
Shure:  唉就特别的耻辱
Shure: You know?
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: Do you know?
其他人：有两门吧
Others: There were two courses, right?
其他人：我记得有
Others: I remember there were.
其他人：有一门平时无所谓
Others: One course where regular grades didn't matter.
其他人：有一门平时不行
Others: One course where regular grades mattered.
Shure:  唉我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  反正他不是他自己亲口说的
Shure: Anyway, he didn't keep his word.
Shure:  然后最后搞这种
Shure: And in the end, this happened.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Jake: 走吧还眼镜
Jake: Let's go, return the glasses.
Shure:  好disconnect finish
Shure: Alright, disconnect finished.
Shure:  完了我这又没有那个finish那个键
Shure: Oh no, I don't have the finish button again.
Alice:yes啊好了
Alice: Yes, okay.
Shure:  connecting oh okay
Shure: Connecting... oh, okay.